aquí tengo un rectángulo que de largo
mide siete octavos de un metro y de
ancho mide cinco novenos de un metro y
te invito a que pienses cuál es el área
el área de este rectángulo y bueno para
eso pausa el vídeo y ver si puedes
obtenerla
bueno una manera de encontrar su área es
simplemente multiplicar el largo por el
ancho o la base por la altura es decir
vamos a multiplicar estos siete octavos
de un metro estos siete octavos de un
metro que es una de estas dimensiones
déjenme ponerlos voy a multiplicar estos
siete octavos de un metro por bueno la
otra dimensión
voy a multiplicarlo por la altura que es
cinco novenos de un metro déjame ponerlo
con este color cinco novenos de un metro
cinco novenos de metro muy bien y esto a
que será igual esto va a ser igual am y
en un principio voy a obtener metros
cuadrados si multiplicó estos metros por
estos metros voy a obtener metros
cuadrados y luego voy a tener siete por
cinco en el numerador déjame ponerlo con
este color 7 que multiplica a 5 y así
voy a obtener que el numerador es 35 y
bueno en el denominador tengo 8 por 9 8
por 9 lo cual me va a dar un numerador
de 72 y con esto ya lo tenemos el área
de este rectángulo es de 35 70 y 12 años
de un metro cuadrado muy bien pero ahora
lo que quiero hacer es que pensemos un
poco más a profundidad porque esto tiene
sentido o simplemente que veamos una
manera distinta de resolver este
problema
eso lo que voy a hacer es separar esta
región que tengo aquí en rectángulos
iguales déjame hacerlo y la voy a
separar por aquí y lo que quiero que
notes es que en esta ocasión tenemos a
déjeme ver 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 rectángulos en
la base y tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 rectángulos
de altura lo que quiere decir que
tenemos 5 x 7 rectángulos de los nuevos
es decir dividir el rectángulo grande de
color rosa en 35 pequeños rectángulos
déjame escribirlo por aquí tenemos 35
rectángulos muy bien y si ahora me
pregunto cuál es el área de cada uno de
los rectángulos bueno pues observa lo
siguiente primero pensemos en la base de
cada uno de estos rectángulos y si
observas tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
rectángulos iguales y sabíamos que desde
aquí
hasta acá teníamos una longitud de siete
octavos de metro por lo tanto si pienso
en solamente uno de estos rectángulos en
solamente uno de estos rectángulos y me
pregunto cuál es su base bueno pues ya
puedes responder que su base va a ser
solamente una séptima parte de siete
octavos de metro o dicho otra manera un
octavo de meta
un octavo de metro y con la misma lógica
podemos pensar en su altura si toda esta
altura mide cinco novenos entonces
cuánto miden solamente esta altura que
tengo aquí esta altura que tengo aquí
bueno pues si dividimos a cinco novenos
de metro en cinco partes iguales
entonces cada una de esas partes tienen
una longitud de un noveno de metro de un
noveno de metro muy bien y si ahora si
nos preguntamos por el área de este
rectángulo que tengo aquí de este
pequeño rectángulo cuál es su área
bueno pues su área ya es muy fácil de
obtener porque va a ser igual a la base
por la altura lo cual me va a quedar uno
noveno de metro por un octavo de metro
esta va a ser el área que estoy buscando
esta área de aquí entonces esto va a ser
igual a 1 por 1 me va a dar 1 en el
numerador en el denominador tengo 9 por
8 lo cual es 72 metros por metros me van
a dar metros cuadrados de lujo el área
de este pequeño rectángulo que tengo
aquí es de 1 sobre 72 metros cuadrados o
de solamente 172 ceav o de metro
cuadrado ahora bien esa es el área de
solamente un rectángulo que tenemos aquí
de uno de los pequeños rectángulos que
tenemos aquí pero tenemos 35 de ellos
para cubrir todo este gran rectángulo de
color rosa que teníamos en un principio
entonces si queremos el área de todo
este rectángulo rosa que teníamos en un
principio habrá que multiplicar 35
el área de cada uno de esos rectángulos
es decir 35 que va a multiplicar que va
a multiplicar a 1 sobre 72 metros
cuadrados metros cuadrados y esto a que
será igual bueno pues esto va a ser
igual a 35 a 35 que es justo este 35 que
tengo aquí entre 72 entre 72 este 35 es
mi numerador 35 por unos 35 y después
tengo 1 por 72 lo cual me da mi
denominador metros cuadrados y ya está
observa que obtuvimos el mismo resultado
que teníamos en un principio entonces
una vez más simplemente puedes
multiplicar 5 novenos de metro por 7
octavos de metro y obtener este
resultado pero ojalá cuando estuvimos
hablando acerca del área
uno de estos rectángulos esto te da una
idea mucho más intuitiva sobre de dónde
proviene este número